welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm Gus docker on this episode I
talk with Vincent bulanin Vincent got
his PhD in political science in 2014 and
now he works as a senior researcher at
the Stockholm International Peace
Research Institute
on this episode we talk about the
positives and negatives of incorporating
artificial intelligence into our nuclear
weapon systems but we mostly focus on
the dangers
including how incorporating AI into
these systems changes the game theory of
war and changes world leader psychology
here is Vincent bulanin
Vincent welcome to the podcast thank you
for being with us
thank you for the invitation it's uh
it's a pleasure I'm a big fan of the
podcast
I think we should start by thinking
about strategic stability so maybe just
introduce us to this idea
yeah I think I think it's it's a good
addition to it's um
it's a concept that can be understood
differently
um there's different definitions so the
term was kind of originally coined
during the Cold War
um to describe the the nature of the
Strategic relationship between the
Soviet Union and the United States
and basically it was used to describe
the absence of incentive for either
country to launch a first nuclear strike
so basically build on the assumption
that stability is achieved
by the fear of mutually assured
destruction so if both sides our
have um or are confident in their own
capability to retaliate or that the
other country might be able to retaliate
to a first try you achieve some form of
stability uh and in a sense that it
would not be kind of incentivized to
build up the nuclear Arsenal
and more or less in case of a crisis
that they would be less under the
pressure to to launch a nuclear strike
um so basically like under that
definition like project stability Builds
on two things a
um
that you need to have some kind of uh
you need to have a second strike
capability so the ability to retaliate
if your opponent is is uh is launching a
first strike and second that
um that
retiratory capability is is credible
um that it will be effective and it will
be able to kind of survive potential uh
nuclear first strike
like the Baseline component of of our
strategic stability is is assured does
that make sense that makes perfect sense
what we're going to talk about in this
conversation is how AI might change
strategic stability and what we're
mostly interested in is how AI could be
potentially a negative in terms of the
stability of the world but if we're
first it might be interested in
interesting to first look into how AI
could be a positive in terms of ensuring
strategic stability one thing you've
researched here is the possibility of
having better early Warning Systems what
can you tell us about this
thanks so about just we kind of kind of
bring a bit of context so as just as I
just said like one of the key component
of
stroke stabilities the the confidence
that states have a credible
uh retaliatory capability right uh that
they will be able to kind of
respond and detect and respond to
potential first strike
um and in that context so AI can be
really helpful
um it can basically can be Abu for the
entire spectrum of you know nuclear
related capabilities in a sense from
from yeah detecting nuclear attacks to
kind of delivering nuclear weapons to
doing nuclear communal control to and
others doing missile defense and
everything but in the context of early
warning and ISR the
way it's helpful because it provides the
advances of machine learning can provide
better kind of situational awareness and
then therefore like more confidence in
that the state is able to kind of
monitor what the the opponent might be
doing and these benefits derive from the
fact that recent advances of of machine
learning basically can unlock uh have
unlocked
significant progress in terms of like
perceptual intelligence so the ability
of computers to
um to uh to make sense of the world
um uh would have been I don't know
computer vision systems that can detect
objects situation of interests people
and everything
um so the idea is that these advances of
machine learning would make ISR systems
much more performant in a sense and that
would be one element and another element
would be that also like using the kind
of the ability of
machine learning to kind of like find
statistical relationship in data you can
also do more kind of advanced automated
kind of intelligence analysis so you can
fuse information from different sources
and to see whether they're interesting
correlation
and that type of like data processing
capability can help uh basically like
decision makers to kind of make
assumptions around the adversaries kind
of action intention
um and ultimately can help them better
kind of foresee or prepare for uh the
next move let's say
and we're thinking about
processing data from satellites here or
which kinds of data are we talking about
that that's uh that's being fed into
these AI systems
so certainly satellite data would be a
critical component but you could also
imagine that there are other type of
data that you can you can use any
anything from
you can vacuum information from uh you
know open source intelligence sources so
things from the internet from
um
like everything from like social media
activity to like press uh press reports
and try to kind of you can analyze these
courses from leaders and try to find
using machine learning to kind of
automate the process of finding
information of interest in terms of and
I know they have they are projects that
are trying to for instance analyze the
political discourse of like North Korea
so that process all the kind of
political speeches that have been made
by different officials to kind of detect
indication of a language that would
that could be um indicating particular
kind of intentions or and so on so these
are just very you know concrete example
of the fact that basically any type of
intelligence information
could be processed in some way by
Machine learning algorithm
and so we are would this be part of an
early warning system if we're talking
about analyzing open sources from North
North Korea for example from North Korea
and state TV is is that would you
categorize that as part of of
improvements in early warning systems
I would make a difference between early
Warning Systems which are more perhaps
if you understand the concept narrowly
more the kind of systems that would
allow you to kind of detect an actual
attack or proportion of attack to what
you may more generally call like ISR
systems so systems that provide you
intelligence and or allow you to survey
and uh the actions of of um of other
actors so I think that would be I think
machine learning is useful for at both
levels uh but particularly for the more
ISR aspect where there it's more about
maybe modern long-term uh aspect of like
connecting information processing it
making sense of it
could AI also be used to check whether
countries are upholding their end of the
deal in terms of arms deals or arms
control deals
uh yeah that's that's a very good uh
that's a very good point uh it's
basically the same capabilities that you
have that the state might deploy
for itself in terms of like monitoring
the action of of uh potential
adversaries and detects you know
situation of Interest or movement of
troops or any other type of activities
that might be worrying
that same you know process can also be
deployed for the more the task of doing
kind of like Arms Control monitoring and
verification
for instance like processing machine
learning can help people that are in
charge of verifying and monitoring
compliance with existing agreements
they could that would help them process
kind of satellite data for instance and
to see whether states are actually
compliant you can can speed up the
process of finding information of
Interest
and I know that there are some
organizations that are exploring that
possibility
um
so and the Federation of American
scientists for instance a U.S think tank
is is trying to kind of put that
approach into practice and they are
trying to explore our machine learning
can can be used to analyze trade data
and and other type of like um open
source information related to kind of
arms control
um and the same with another
organization called NTI and it could
have thread initiative they're also
trying to kind of see whether we can
use machine learning to kind of process
open source data to kind of supplement
existing kind of like monitoring and
verification mechanism
so the overall conclusion here is not
that AI is a pure bad in terms of
increasing the the in terms of upholding
the stability of the world the
conclusion here would be something like
they are potentially specific cases in
which AI could decrease the Strategic
stability or decrease the stability of
the world in general this the stability
in between countries but that there are
there are also other cases in which AI
could help I think maybe now we could we
could move on to these scenarios you've
investigated in terms of how AI could
decrease the stability of the world
which kind of which AI Technologies
could be developed that would make the
world a more dangerous place for nuclear
powers and one of the things you've
investigated is the possibility of
remote sensing submarines so maybe you
could tell us about why are submarines
interesting
um in terms of nuclear strategic
stability
thanks so just be able to tie back to
your last point I mean I I guess the the
key component for strategic stability
with this idea of like the confidence
right so the states have a confidence in
there
ability to kind of retaliate uh and that
the other enemy will will be will not be
incentivized to to do a first right
um so like the application that I
mentioned before can potentially
increase that confidence that they are
better prepared
um but the same
um you know capabilities that provide
you with more confidence can also
trigger insecurity from your adversary
and that's that's
one of the you know the the other side
of the comment in a sense and that that
brings me to this uh this question of
um remote sensing and submarines that
you just uh introduced
so basically like as I said like you
know having a credible red territory
capability is critical uh and
usually one considered like uh that
certain Marines are the kind of the the
ultimate kind of like deterrence tool or
like because it's the arguably the most
survivable kind of nuclear delivery
platform
they're on the Water The Operators offer
a very large
um uh territory their mobile uh
detecting things on the water is usually
very difficult so basically like when
you have submarines that are deployed
you know that your enemy will have a
very hard time finding out where they
are and adding a preemptive strike on uh
yosemore so this this idea that
basically like summarize an immune to a
preventive strike position so that's
that makes the kind of the ultimate
retaliation tool
and this is what this is what you mean
by nuclear submarines being survivable
correct yes exactly so so now to go back
to the AI conversation
there is uh one of the scenario that
comes up in the in the literature when
you talk to expert is the possibility
that AI
um especially when you talk about
embodied AI like physically deploying
autonomous systems for remote sensing
for basically collecting data and you
know sensing the the environment
um that could undermine
um the survivability of uh submarines or
at least he would make them harder to
kind of to hide and to stay undetected
and
they build on the assumption that uh so
aai can can allow you to kind of deploy
or develop and deploy more autonomous uh
platforms so like AR Drones but also on
the water
um systems that potentially you could
develop in large numbers
and deploy knowledge numbers and have
them roam over like you know a large a
large area and basically that if you
have a lot of systems like that are just
kind of like loitering around in the
ocean that would be harder for for
submarines to hide and then that's
something that could then trigger
insecurity from the side of the
countries that usually rely on this
submarines for as a deterrent capability
so that's that's one of the
uh scenario that has been discussed it's
hotly debated whether that that actually
is uh a problem there are some people
that believe that actually that the idea
that he would kind of like change that
they would be a game changer is kind of
like
um yeah some people kind of question
that
notably uh if I may like
um I guess the main reason is that
detecting things on the water is still
very hard
um so you may have a lot of uh
underwater vehicles but uh the the real
the laws of physics makes that the
environment underwater of environment
are you know they are just very hard to
observe with actual sensors so you know
the environment distorts signals and and
so on so it's you know it's not very
efficient it's not like you can have
like when you're in the air you can have
a camera that provide you like a high
resolution picture right it doesn't
doesn't work in underwater
um so basically like it's still how to
detect things on the water uh so you
need to have a lot of systems uh out
there and also there's all through the
Practical difficulty of okay what if you
detect a submarines that is kind of like
passing by you need to potentially need
to track it and then somebody's can they
can travel very quickly uh some of them
are nuclear powered and so they go very
fast so that the tracking of of
submarines would be an actual which is
practical difficulty so
um so it's not like suddenly like
submarines would be a totally kind of
threatened and no longer or become
obsolete in a sense yeah so it's
difficult to develop this technology
because of just the vastness of the
ocean and maybe the opting Optics of
water and so on so even if we have
advanced AI uh trying to find these
submarines they will just just from the
inherent physics of of spotting
submarines it's it's an it's an it's a
very complex problem
yeah I mean in a sense that he was not
he would not be as effective as some
people would assume
um the perhaps the one situation where
you could make a difference
um is for instance for states that don't
have a lot of submarines uh or because
of the you know where they are in the
world their summaries would have to
travel in specific areas so you could
imagine that potentially people could
try to kind of
concentrate the deployment of the
sensing autonomous systems in like what
you may call Choke points or like points
where they would assume that submarines
might travel through uh either to kind
of go on you know to go for uh some
reconnaissance or whatever
um so that that could be a possibility
that it would make things harder
potentially for some of these countries
to travel in some key areas that where
they are supposed to to loiter or to to
maneuver
so that's one possibility that again
then the ultimate question is whether
that would undermine their confidence in
um in their retirement capability it's
not stupid
so that's one possibility the
possibilities that that AI would make it
easier to spot submarines thereby
undermining the confidence of Nations
who are relying on nuclear submarines
for their deterrence effect another
possibility would be to that AI could
enhance Conventional Weapons which would
make it more diff or which would make it
easier to attack nuclear targets with
Conventional Weapons how realistic is
this scenario
um that's that's a good question I mean
in in the expert field we call that the
antonym problem so the idea that
uh as kind of Conventional Weapons
become kind of better uh it might become
more feasible to use them against uh
nuclear assets
and there's the concern that AI is one
of that technological development that
contributes to making Conventional
Weapons much more efficient
um and there are different you know you
can yeah I can do that in different ways
uh first of all you can you can use
machine learning to make to further
develop the missile Guidance the
guidance systems of missiles for
instance so you can make Precision guide
emissions that are that are that are
better for instance you you can I know
that there are research that is looking
at using machine learning to kind of
develop the control systems of
hypersonic missiles so that they would
be better at evading and penetrating air
defenses so that's one thing
you could also rely on the recent
progress of AI to kind of
deploy more autonomous stealthy combat
drones again which could be deployed to
strike nuclear assets
so that's another possibility
a third possibility would be that you
use AI more in the Cyber operation realm
so the idea of like you can use AI to
kind of conduct cyber offensive
operation against the nuclear common
control of your adversary
uh one in against a jargon term but it's
called the kind of left of launch
operations so the idea that you would
you would attack the common control so
that the enemy would not be able to
launch an attack
um so that's another possibility and
finally you can also use AI to kind of
um
for like electronic warfare where you
would try to defeat the defenses of your
enemy
um through one by form of jamming and
other kind of yeah electronic base kind
of like attacks and you can use machine
learning to kind of better understand
the signals of their systems and and
develop kind of like jamming
possibilities
what about incorporating AI directly
into nuclear command and control systems
I'm specifically thinking about
incorporating AI into nuclear launch
systems it seems to me to be the most
the scariest possibility our countries
attempting to do this how realistic is
it that this would happen
thanks that's a good question so these
two there are two dimensions of it so
there's the
using Adventure AI for the delivery
aspect that's one thing where you can
use AI to kind of have more autonomous
kind of delivery platform
um that might not be such a game
changing in the sense where you know
when you think of uh one of the critical
kind of uh nuclear deliver platform this
intercontinental ballistic missiles they
are you know once they are launched more
or less they they operate autonomously
they go to their targets and you know
that's they are not remote control
um
and possibly like you could imagine that
you know you could have unmanned uh
on crude bombers that would be more or
less autonomous in there
um
that's one other thing but I'm not sure
you would be a game changer and also
like apparently like states are
generally like not very confident with
the idea of using
on crude systems like Uncle bombers or
on crude submarines for for nuclear
um weapon delivery uh for political and
security reasons Russia being the kind
of the exception uh because they have
declared that
um they are developing this this
autonomous torpedo called the Poseidon
which can operate autonomously and could
be used for nuclear delivery
uh but at the time they they argued that
they still want to have some form of
human
control over the decision to launch
um so it's kind of okay uh but in
general I think there's a sense that
um
States
the other dimensions that I deliver as I
just talked about the delivery aspect
but the critical aspect as you said is
model launch decision
from the research that we've done
and and when we talk to expert the
general sense for that ball is no state
is interested in in automated that
decision ecosystem perhaps the most
political
you know decision people have to make
like whether they will use nuclear
weapons or not because what is at stake
is basically like you know the security
or the entire world so it's it's looking
fairly unlikely possibility that that
process will be a kind of like not
purely automated
but we cannot exclude you know
um that there might be some situation
where some states might be tempted by
the option uh and why would the why
would they be tempted by that option uh
which state might be tempted by that
option
the only things that can talk in favor
of that option uh is the fact that
arguably that has been done in the past
for deterrence reasons so there has been
reports that the that the Soviet Union
had developed a form of Sumi automated
retaliatory system in the case of a
decapitating attack on the
political and military command
um so if it was like a very kind of even
then kind of decision tree up so if the
entire
kind of Russian like Soviet Union
command and control was was killed
if no one was responding to kind of uh
some uh two calls and so on and then the
decision would be to kind of launch a
territory attack or to more or less
automatically so there will still be
some people involved in the action of
launching but but the decision tree was
very kind of like
more less than Euro minute so that
happened in the past arguably
that system is still
um online they have the Russian
Federation that's uh as mid statements
that seem to indicate that
could argue that system might still be
active but um and that could be a
yeah that's the the purpose of it is
just meaning to kind of dissuade
um that are possible for strike against
the territory I guess um saying that if
if you try to kind of you know I don't
know like launch a nuclear strike on
Moscow
um there will be there will be a
response whatever
um and it's not impossible that some
some countries which are very insecure
um could be tempted by the possibility
so we've talked about now some some
possibilities where AI might help
develop new technology that could
decrease the stability of the world but
there's also the
Game Theory and leader psychology of AI
development here I'm thinking about kind
of an AI capabilities race between
states which I think it would be driven
by by the the game theory of leaders
reacting to other leaders developing AI
maybe we could talk about what is what
is such a such a a capability arms race
it's a good question so
as a professed as a predict to underline
the fact that in the field strategy
things are highly psychological so
the perception of your enemy's
capability matters as much as the actual
capability so
that point might be worth underlining
here why why would it be the case that
the perception of a state's capability
would matter as much as the state's
actual capability
because in the case of AI
um
it's potentially because it's to large
extent an intangible technology that is
not visible to the naked eye
um
there's not necessarily a lot of like
empirical evidence of what the
capabilities of the country's uh of the
country is in that domain right so it's
not like you can count the number of
Tanks or the number of silos or missiles
when you talk about the use of your in
some potential nuclear or other
conventional um systems
um it's hard to assess so like then
that's where we talk about you know it's
just a belief that another state might
have some capabilities might trigger
some reaction and that's that what is
potentially concerning who they are
because it's harder to get a sense of
what the adversaries capabilities are
that it could trigger something to kind
of like you know take true conclusions
and decide to kind of react accordingly
one way to react as you just said is to
engage in um an arms race on the eye or
like a capability race on the eye like
also trying to kind of develop AI
capabilities and try to integrate these
capabilities within military systems in
including potentially nuclear related
systems that would be
a possibility and the reality is is that
it's kind of already the case where
there are already evidence that there's
a kind of a strategy competition on AI
between major Powers including
especially nuclear armed States
we looked at that and all of them have
released policy documents
that kind of indicate an Ambitions to
kind of like
be part of that kind of great power
competition on the eye I mean perhaps
the exception is is North Korea because
the sources are not you know
are you available let's say but when it
comes to China France India Russia the
UK the us we have all fund documents
that indicate that they want to kind of
invest in AI for military reasons
these documents do not always make the
direct connection with nuclear uh but
it's basically indicate that the CEI is
a key element of their future
capabilities so that's they give an
impression that there is
already so kind of an arms race
um on on that
so in a sense the arms race has already
begun because all states have
noted that their interest in developing
um AI capabilities for for military
purposes and I have any states indicated
that they want to abstain from engaging
in and on in an arms race
I mean when it comes to kind of nuclear
arm stays I mean obviously the you know
arms race is a very loaded term so
they would not be you know mention it or
took took about it in that way uh I I
guess
what is the concern and that that is
shared by a number of of new clown
States
is the possibility that as states are
you know trying to kind of compete on
that front that some of them might be
tempted to kind of do a race to the
bottom in terms of the eye safety that
did the in order to try to keep up they
will be less
concerned about
um standards of like testing and
evaluation and that basically that they
might adopt AI in an irresponsible way
in a premature way deploy systems that
are not tested that have not that might
not be highly reliable
and the fear is that if they do so with
some states do so that it could increase
the risk of having
um
yeah technologies that perform in a way
that would not be adequate and that
trick could trigger some incident that
could have potentially dramatic
consequences so
so maybe we could look at the incentives
from the perspective of the states that
are say economically and militarily
weaker than other states their incentive
is to try to catch up in AI development
so as to not be left behind
and could this then cause the states
that are more advanced economically and
militarily to see their the the see the
actions of the weaker States as a as an
escalation and then you have kind of
like a feedback cycle where uh where
nuclear states are reacting to the
actions that they're each taking
yeah and I think that's that's the
that's the
what we call the security dilemma right
so things that states might do to
increase their security so building up
an Arsenal uh investing more might
trigger the insecurity of the adversary
that in turn might react in ways that
then will undermine potentially your own
security so that's a kind of a virtual
cycle in a sense so the question is how
how that visual cycle can be controlled
in a way or and mitigated
um so that you don't have this kind of
like destabilizing kind of like Armament
Dynamics
um that would yeah
especially in periods of tension or
crisis could have dramatic effect
you've investigated a number of
foreseeable risk scenarios for how
things could go wrong with the
implementation of AI nuclear systems and
you distinguish between accidental
escalation inadvertent escalation and
deliberate escalation let's maybe talk
about accidental escalation first and
specifically how this might happen with
AI
uh thanks so
I guess The Accidental escalations as I
said it's it's it's about the idea that
things might escalate without actual
intention to escalate
um and one I mean the The Logical
pathway is that basically
there's a kind of attention right so on
the sense AI is supposed to kind of give
commanders or military should make a
better information it should supposed to
kind of allow them to process
information more larger volume more
quickly and make better decisions
quicker
the challenge is that for the Paradox is
that it's
can also increase the pace of warfare as
p as states can make decisions quicker
also deploy because we like execute the
station more quickly using autonomous
systems and so on that might you know
increase the speed of warfare
which in turn reduce the decision making
time and further incentivize to automate
um the kind of like The Kill chain or
whatever like the decision making
process and and so on so as this kind of
like as part of the decision making
process gets
more automated or more reliant on
automatic processes and states also rely
more potentially on autonomous systems
including automatic weapons then there's
there is that should a technical event
happen that could have that could
trigger accidental escalation and we
have seen
example in the password
um
they were some issues between the
interaction between the human and the
human decision making especially when
the situation was very kind of like time
sensitive that that triggers some
yeah some development that were
problematic
what's the example you have in mind here
so I guess I mean the the most famous
example which is which eventually did
not lead to an escalation was the the
Petrov incident in 1983
where basically like the system the
early warning system detected uh an
attack from the US
um
and
if the the picture of the Commander in
charge at the time just follow these two
I mean follow the information that the
system was providing
that could have basically like triggered
a return
the third third world war nuclear war
and everything it didn't happen
in in that case because
um
the commander didn't have sufficient
trust in the system and used kind of
common sense that allow them to kind of
understand that okay that might not make
sense
maybe I'll I'm gonna hold off and try to
kind of
uh on that basically save the world so
uh so uh it's uh is a hero for that but
there are also other incidents in the
past where things didn't get as you know
things didn't turn out as well when
there have been
we have been exempt to factory sides
where um one example is the is where in
in Iraqi in 2003 where the US
missile defense system the patriarch was
involved in two fat results so basically
the The Operators were were you know you
they didn't have enough time to kind of
verify the information they had to make
a call and they ended up shooting their
own you know colleagues uh
um so like uh he was friendly fire
basically
um yeah so these are some of the the
problems that emerge from from the kind
of um yeah the increased Reliance on
automative processes so the classic Pro
there are three classic problem a you
over rely on the system and that can
lead to an accident so the system is
failing it's missing misidentifying
something and you rely on it and
boom that's that was the the wrong
decision or you you don't trust it
enough and
you were misinterpret your data and you
you
um you act on it so there have been also
example of some commercial aircraft that
have been
uh destroyed uh notably one in
uh in the year on flight 655 in 1988
that was uh destroyed by the Aegis
combat system in the on a warship called
the USS Vincent
um that's another example
and and then the patch up example that I
mentioned is more like the third problem
in terms of like what we call the out of
the loop problem where basically like
you you are you have people sort of
monitoring the system nothing is
happening for hours and then suddenly
within the space of minutes they have to
kind of make a judgment call like okay
can I this is telling that we are
there's an attack going on I have three
minutes to react what should I do and we
we know there's a lot of research on
that that shows that regaining
situational awareness and making this
decision initial so a short amount of
time can be can be challenging
so that really is the core of the
problem the fact that automated systems
shorten decision time Cycles such that
the humans that are supposed to check
whether they're automated systems are
doing their job correctly have
what are we talking minutes to make a
decision and then
I mean you can just imagine yourself in
this situation under immense time
pressure you have knowledge of how big
the stakes involved are and then you
have to make a decision you could you
can easily imagine all sorts of
um biases uh all sorts of biased human
cognition happening in that scenario
maybe we should talk about the
difference between accidental escalation
that we just covered and then
inadvertent escalation what it what is
inadvertent escalation and what's the
difference between two things
I guess it's it's connected to the
notion of intentionality so uh in the
accident parties there were no intention
but in the case of inadvertent attacking
like this some kind of intention like
there's a decision that is made to
escalate but perhaps the basis on which
that decision is made is is wrong or is
is uh
and a basic example would be
say
you have a situation where
let me roll back a bit the Baseline is
because AI is a said earlier like it's a
it's a it's not you can observe the cap
the AI capabilities of the system or
whether a system is autonomous like just
by looking at it so you have let's say
you have a drone coming at you
it might be difficult for the person who
is detecting the Drone to make an
assessment whether that's a remotely
controlled drone whether it's an
autonomous drone
it's also not necessarily clear what the
Drone is out there to do whether it's
just to collect information to do
reconnaissance or whether it's could be
there to kind of launch an attack and
then there's also if it's a large one
they could be what
um uncertainty around the payload
whether it's a conventional payload or
potentially a nuclear payload
would be a situation where a drone is
coming
and
then the person with detect the German
might mistake that mistake a mistake the
intention or might say okay maybe that
that drone is coming is is intended to
kind of launch a strike and um I need to
respond
by I don't know destroying that drone or
that could have and then that's a that's
an intentional escalation that is that
can have that can then trigger a chain
of events um so that's that's one
scenario that we identify in our work
when we talk to um
to people then to what extent that will
be the case in reality that's that's
much more complex
um problem there are many examples in
the past where they have been as
incident with drones and so on and
doesn't not necessarily led to
escalation but that's that's one
possibility that um that we discussed so
even the perception that a system might
be autonomous could increase risk so
this is again the the case in which
um perception matters a lot in these
scenarios it's not necessarily that I
wouldn't tie it to the autonomous aspect
to be honest I think it's more about
uh what the system is out to do I guess
so I mean whether it's remotely
controlled or autonomous don't do the
what changes with autonomy is the fact
that perhaps it may be harder to jam the
system and jam the communication link
between the platform and the command so
if it's an autonomous platform that is
out for doing a you know a targeted
strike it might be harder to kind of
yeah to use that that Avenue to kind of
like defeat the system like it's it will
be like more resistant to kind of
communication deny and everything
there's a complicating Factor but the
the fundamental question is the question
of signaling whether to understand the
intention of the enemy and if the
intentions are mistaken that could
trigger escalatory chain of event
what about the case of deliberate
escalation how could AI be involved here
thanks so I guess it
for deliberator escalation
um that ties back to the question of
confidence so we are in our work we
identified kind of two two scenarios
uh the first one would be that
the state would decide to launch a
preemptive strike based on let's say AI
based information
showing that the enemy is preparing a
surprise attack
um so all the Intel that you have
collected and you have process of that
data you have used remote sensors and
everything that give you
um information that something might run
away and then for
to ensure that you will have a strategic
Advantage you decide to strike first
that could be one possibility it's a
very you might argue a bit far-fetched
but that's that's one
um the second scenario would be um
where there's a major kind of like
imbalance in terms of like between the
two states in terms of not having the
conventional domain so you are one state
that
um if they know that they are not able
to complete at the conventional level
because they are fighting against the
state that's much more technology
advanced they have like a fighter craft
drones and everything
um various type of missiles and so on
um that yeah they could be tempted to
kind of use nuclear weapons as a
preemptively to kind of deter
um
um
yeah they tell the other states to kind
of um
engage but then obviously like then the
question whether it's a it would be kind
of political suicide because they would
trigger a chain of command but that's a
scenario that I've been discussing the
in the literature
um and I guess maybe one thing to
undermine I think at the end of the day
I mean
AI would just be one component
of a much larger
set of contextual like elements that
would determine whether things kind of
skeletal or not there is a lot of things
related to what's happening on the at
the politically in that very situation
whether there's already business
intention What actors we are talking
about all of them might react
differently
great so we've discussed how advances in
AI technology could threaten the
Strategic stability of the world and
we've discussed how Game Theory and
leader psychology surround in the kind
of the AI space could could also
threaten strategic stability if you were
to
in your expert opinion what what is the
biggest potential problem here what
what's the most important thing to get
right
that's a good question I guess
the num these two things a on one endlet
we know that the adoption of recent
advances over another machine learning
will not be
they might take some time in general
generally because like we assume that
states are very conservative when it
comes to Integrity new technologies in
their nuclear you know deterrence
architecture
but I guess the challenge is that uh
earlier like what is concerning would be
a race to the bottom on AI safety the
fact that some states might decide to
adopt AI too quickly irresponsibly
and deploy systems that are not be
highly reliable or too automated
and that would then fuel the or increase
the risk of um yeah basically what we
call nuclear risk so the risk of of
having a situation escalate to nuclear
weapon use I guess that's the
that's the concern that
that AI might rather than reduce
nuclearies might fuel the nuclear risk
so the possibility that something could
escalate to a nuclear lab
that's certainly a scary possibility
Vincent uh thank you for speaking with
me it's been very informative thank you
for having me it was a pleasure
except for this episode on the next
episode I talk with Vincent about what
we can do to mitigate the dangers we've
just discussed hope to see you there